ils s'écrivent j'aime monsieur coca
bonjour team cher shoji se salue
j'espère que vous vous portez bien il y
a trop longtemps qu'on s'est vus nous
allons bien qu'en est il de vous et
votre famille
la journée se termine à montréal elle
commence à tokyo nous avons tous très
hâte de nous retrouver à montréal pour
une réunion après la pandémie
je suis très enthousiaste à l'idée de
vous revoir à montréal et de continuer
nos discussions
ils ont un projet un projet secret ce
serait inapproprié pour moi d'endosser
publiquement le projet d'une compagnie
en particulier le plus grand soin est
nécessaire pour que cette information ne
soit pas divulguée et ces gens ne sont
pas n'importe qui ni au japon ni ici
le 20e premier ministre du canada il
semble entretenir leurs contacts ou
sommet du pouvoir
bonne nouvelle les libéraux sont de
retour c'est un projet secret que nous
allons maintenant révélé publiquement
une source nous a remis une série de
courriels échangés en 2019 et 2020 dépôt
géologique en profondeur des
combustibles nucléaires usés
[Musique]
un projet secret de site de stockage de
déchets nucléaires
ici au canada qui se discute entre
hommes d'affaires canadiens américains
et japonais
à l'issue des premiers concernés vous
[Musique]
la série de courriels révèle des
échanges entre plusieurs personnes qui
s'écrivent en anglais pour bien
comprendre il faut les lire
attentivement la référence aux déchets
nucléaires capte immédiatement notre
attention
spontanément les cinq questions
classiques du journalisme se bousculent
dans notre tête ou qui quand où pourquoi
mais commençons par la base le quoi
nous allons département des sciences de
la terre et de l'environnement de
l'université d'ottawa rencontré le
professeur ian clark il plus
certainement nous renseigner sur des
termes qui reviennent dans les courriels
et le vent quand on parle dans mes
documents des dj ce sont les termes que
je lis dans les documents de quoi on
parle exactement c'est vrai ma commune
avec un puits en profondeur et des
galeries qui sort do en profondeur pour
avoir des espaces vraiment poster que le
nucléaire
la finlande a déjà un site de genre une
méthode plus sécuritaire que d'autres
selon plusieurs scientifiques pour
disposer des déchets très radioactifs
le canada a aussi un projet en marche en
ontario qui a fait l'objet d'un
reportage de nos collègues de découverte
ça c'est le combustible qui alimente les
centrales nucléaires cette grappe n'est
pas radioactives
mais lorsqu'elle sera placé dans une
centrale elle deviendra un déchet qui
demeurera radioactifs pendant des
centaines de milliers d'années
au canada on veut construire un tombeau
nucléaire pour enterrer 5 millions de
ces grappes
mais le projet discuté dans les
courriels que nous avons obtenu n'est
pas celui dont on débat publiquement en
ontario c'est ailleurs mais où les
japonais sont très intéressés par un
dépôt géologique en profondeur dans le
bouclier précambrien au canada
[Musique]
pourquoi cela a été un style des
japonais d'où viendraient ces déchets
qu'on veut stocker quelque part dans le
bouclier canadien
creusons de ce côté là philippe mesmer
journalistes à tokyo connaît bien la
situation des déchets nucléaires au
japon
dix ans après la catastrophe de
fukushima ou trois réacteurs ont fondu à
la suite d'un grave une amie le japon
avant fukushima avait 54 électeurs en
fonction ce qui veut dire que ont une
consommation de combustible nucléaire
qui est importante et qui se traduit par
la production de déchets alors c'est un
très très gros problème surtout qu'en
plus il ya 21 réacteurs qui vont être
démantelées dans les années qui viennent
ici et il semble qu'ils ont entreposés
des déchets radioactifs sous terre n'est
pas simple au japon mais le problème
c'est que comme d'une selle et japon
c'est une paire sismique donc une terre
qui bouge beaucoup et donc il ya
beaucoup de problèmes pour déterminer un
site idéal donc la question du stockage
des déchets se pose pour les japonais il
dans les courriels nous trouvons cet
extrait ou un homme politique canadien
très connu
10 au japonais que le canada pourrait
offrir une solution à leurs problèmes de
déchets nucléaires j'ai confiance que
des canadiens tourné vers l'avenir
seront utilisés les ressources
nécessaires pour la réalisation d'un
dépôt de portée mondiale pour la
livraison et le stockage sécuritaire des
combustibles nucléaires usés on comprend
maintenant pourquoi ils s'écrivent leur
plan de match c'est d'importer des
déchets nucléaires japonais pour les
stocker ici au canada pour toujours pas
si ça se faisait ça serait sensationnel
parce que ça ne s'est jamais fait et il
ya de bonnes raisons pourquoi ça s'est
pas fait basé à paris michael snyder est
un consultant indépendant en énergie
nucléaire
son expertise et rechercher partout dans
le monde tant par les universités les
entreprises que les gouvernements d'une
part cédé matière extrêmement
radioactive donc extrêmement dangereux
pour donner une idée à un mètre de
distance si un combustible irradié n'est
pas protégé la dose létale crâne humain
c'est en moins d'une minute
à notre demande il a lu les courriels
que nous avons obtenu la première
réaction a été une stupéfaction à quel
point des gens extrêmement haut placés
se rassemblent dans une espèce de
conspiration incroyable une conspiration
clairement destiné à garder au secret un
plan est de le faire avancer
suffisamment loin pour confronter les
décideurs avec des fait accompli pour
michael snyder ce genre de projet doit
être mené par des gouvernements
c'est par définition des questions qui
doivent être gérés dans l'intérêt public
et
et en aucun cas dans l'intérêt de
quelques sociétés privées que ce soit
donc c'est déjà la démarche en soi est
extrêmement problématique par l'origine
de cette démarche et nous voici à la
question du qui qui sont ces gens qui
s'écrivent à propos de ce projet sont
ils sérieux est capable de le mener à
bien
d'abord il y à un ancien premier
ministre canadien dont on vous parlera
plus tard et les autres le cerveau aux
scientifiques de l'opération est un
américain du nom de tim frey jours
c'est quelqu'un qui a tué qui a une
position très élevé actuellement il est
vice présidente de ti thaçi il est
quelqu'un qui a un passé de hauts
responsables du ministère de l'énergie
du département le manager aux états unis
parmi les personnes impliquées dont j'ai
connaissance ceylan clé en parallèle de
son emploi chez geely hitachi team
fraîcheur est l'un des principaux
actionnaires de terra volts l'entreprise
impliquée dans le projet secret le site
internet tout aussi secret est bloqué
par un mot de passe
nous l'avons contacté il a refusé nous
parut on découvre aussi dans les
courriels son partenaire l'homme
d'affaires montréalais albert barbucci
on l'appelle pour en savoir davantage
[Musique]
pat dossier mais plusieurs courriels
envoyait des japonais des noms que nous
ne connaissons pas alors nous demandons
l'aide de notre collaborateur à tokyo je
pense que pas qu il y aura de taulis est
vraiment important takuya tories à ses
joues conseil japonais de gestion des
déchets nucléaires
c'est vraiment quelqu'un de très très
très important dans le monde dont ce
qu'on appelle le village nucléaire ici
l'autre nom qui revient souvent dans les
courriels et celui d'isaac fumiko gars à
la tête d'une grande société de
relations publiques japonaises
un second cas aussi il est très
important parce que par sa position et
puis parce que il est aussi un homme de
réseau un homme relativement secret qui
qui connaît beaucoup de monde là on a
avec ces deux personnalités on a
vraiment de deux acteurs importants des
réseaux politico industrielle du japon
il n'y a absolument aucune question que
les japonais impliqués dans ce plan
secret sont des gens de haut profil
maintenant qu'on sait qui parle dans les
courriels
il faut trouver où précisément ils
veulent faire ce projet on trouve la
réponse dans la lettre de l'ancien
premier ministre canadien le green it
sec du labrador serait parfait pour
cette utilisation
bingo labrador mais albert barbucci
lasnier dans notre conversation qui
s'est poursuivi en anglais
[Musique]
pas d'intérêt particulier pour
terre-neuve pourtant voici de göteborg
qui a été premier ministre de la
province jusqu'à l'an dernier à ses
côtés son chef de cabinet greg morceau
avant la politique il était lobbyiste
pour plusieurs compagnies dont une qui
nous intéresse particulièrement nous a
appris notre collègue de sib ici à saint
jean pire au cas où une compagnie qui a
attiré toute l'attention c'est est apte
à style parce qu'ils sont très impliqués
avec le gouvernement mais greg basso
travaillait aussi pour de plus petites
compagnies comme tera vol
terra volts
c'est la compagnie de tim frey jeu pour
le site de stockage de déchets
nucléaires
ils savaient donc un lobbyiste dans le
bureau du premier ministre de
terre-neuve et labrador qui
contrairement à ce que nous a dit albert
barbucci la politique de cette province
semble clean dans leurs projets il écrit
à ses partenaires japonais qu'ils y sont
encore bien branché cherche nissan
comme vous le savez peut-être le premier
ministre baird a annoncé qu'il va
démissionner et qu'un nouveau chef sera
nommé le 3 août cela dit nous prévoyons
rester en contact avec le premier
ministre bat o
de sorte que la transition devrait se
faire en douceur une transition
politique en douceur pour servir leurs
intérêts mais ils ont un atout bien plus
important dans leur jeu un homme dont on
vante les contacts et c'est ainsi que
cette enquête sur un site de stockage de
déchets nucléaires nous ont menés tout
droit dans le salon chez jean chrétien
accepter des déchets nucléaires à
l'étranger ça veut dire importer des
déchets pour toujours canada c'est
pourquoi j'y sens vont d'un sous-sol
disent pas grave au labrador
j'ai pas mal mieux que mourir
[Musique]
revenons au point de départ de cette
enquête les courriels
après l'étonnante découverte d'un projet
inédit pour enfouir les déchets
nucléaires étrangers au canada on a eu
une deuxième surprise la présence de
jean chrétien et dans notre démarche
on a eu une troisième surprise c'est que
jean chrétien a accepté de nous donner
une entrevue vous allez voir que c'était
pas partie pour ça nous avons appelé
jean chrétien pour la première fois 5
février
oui bonjour jean chrétien est copiée
dans certains courriels que nous avons
obtenus et on parle de lui dans
plusieurs autres le projet en tant que
tel c'est quoi d'accord parlons à albert
barbucci l'un des responsables pour
éclaircir le rôle de jean chrétien et
messieurs crétin de vente
certains peuvent faire beaucoup de
choses en vingt minutes comme
concrétiser une longue lettre de jean
chrétien ou potentiels partenaires
japonais du projet est-ce que vous avez
parlé à des japonais qui sont engagés
dans ce projet selon les courriels jean
chrétien a pris une part beaucoup plus
active qu'il a d'abord dit ou que le
souhaitent l'admettre albert barbucci
[Musique]
oui on a une copie de la lettre que jean
chrétien a signé il y a moins de 18 mois
à l'attention d'un haut dirigeant d'une
compagnie japonaise de relations
publiques au cours de mes plus de 40 ans
au sein du gouvernement et dans la vie
publique
j'ai cultivé un vif intérêt pour tous
les aspects de l'énergie nucléaire
jean chrétien plaide pour faire du
canada une destination permanente pour
les déchets nucléaires de partout dans
le monde
bien qu'il serait inapproprié pour moi
ce stade-ci d'endosser le projet d'une
entreprise en particulier
j'ai toujours été publiquement
favorables à l'énergie nucléaire et le
concept d'un dépôt géologique en
profondeur dans le nord est du canada
nous avons fait lire cette lettre par
michael snyder consultant international
en énergie nucléaire
ce que je trouve incroyablement
scandaleux c'est que quelqu'un avec ce
profil à utilise son nom pour ouvrir des
portes pour un projet qui est totalement
clandestin un projet en dehors de tout
tout contrôle public en aussi consulté
le professeur de sciences politiques
denis saint martin dans ma recherche
avec d'autres on appelle ça la politique
silencieuse
donc ça ça se fait exactement comme
décrivant les courriels clairement ce
n'était pas dans leurs plans de parler
publiquement de leur projet maintenant
eux il y aura eu le temps d'aligner
leurs pions pendant 3 4 10 ans donc ils
vont aller sans chercher des autochtones
favorable à leur projet ils vont aller
chercher des certifications de
greenpeace ou d'autres organismes
mondiale qui vont dire que c'est beau
puis que oui c'est dans l'intérêt
national canadien et ce dans l'intérêt
mondial
de le faire on tente une dernière fois
d'en savoir plus
on rappelle jean chrétien pour lui dire
qu'on a sa lettre c'est à ce moment là
qu à notre grande surprise le plan de
match change
il nous invite chez lui pour nous
accorder une entrevue pas eu de
tremblement terre qu'on sache au
labrador
c'est un acte extrême a dû alors l'idée
c'est de faire des forages et d'aller
déposer les déchets nucléaires à 5000
pièces dyson et nous le canada ont été
les vendeurs d'uranium
c'est à dire qu'on a profité de ce
problème parce qu'on a vendu le gagnant
alors on a une responsabilité d'aider à
régler le problème des déchets qui
pourraient venir du japon et même
d'ailleurs
le canado vannes de l'uranium à travers
le monde comme le dévoile quelque pays
que ce soit alors que s'il y en a qui
veulent d lopp et veulent payer pour ont
pour pour ceux qui ne le connaissent pas
jean chrétien a été premier ministre du
canada pendant dix ans jusqu'en 2003
depuis lors ils travaillent dans big
grands cabinets d'avocats
présentement il est chez gentles mais
dans la lettre il ne signe pas comme
avocat
ce qui me choque au gars qui disent les
collabos et moins que le bureau mama de
sigean vérone dieppe puis doux et
préparer la laine les lubies les signer
vous signez actifs d'anciens premiers
ministres qu'elle mérite ce titre à
écouter j'ai je savais pas que ça écrit
comme ça je me rappelle pas que j'aille
à part que je signe et j'ai lu la dette
et japon' marc sautelet c'est la
première fois que six c'est l'avocat qui
écrit la camisole rien à voir avec votre
énoncé méconnaissance que je veux c'est
un abus de vote c'est de trouver c'est
insoutenable
oui que vous le valez il a envoyé ses
nains le jugement
selon jean chrétien c'est un avocat de
son cabinet théorie des deux qui a
commis cette erreur
des deux c'est responsable du dossier
d'albert barbucci et de tim frey dirty
dancing
il n'a pas souhaité commenter nous avons
un autre courriel où il se réjouit de la
réélection de justin trudeau en octobre
2019 l'écrit gôniots de bronze bac c'est
vrai bernier aux gens ça c'est vous has
not been appointed by justin trudeau
aziz 3-0 et pourquoi écrire ça et oui
mais allez lui demander
non c'est le commerce doivent aux accès
au pouvoir une théorie qui fait c'est
lui qui le fait
j'ai digéré bonnes âmes mais s'il vous
dit que c'est moi qui mène le guen le
maillot temps mais on pourrait penser le
contraire regardez bien ces images
tournées au parlement en novembre 2019
quelques jours après le courriel
triomphe en annonçant la réélection des
libéraux les journalistes font le pied
de grue à l'extérieur de la salle où le
premier ministre justin trudeau
c'est son premier conseil des ministres
soudain les journalistes se déplace
ils ont reconnu jean chrétien qui
s'éloigne dans un corrida
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de nombreuse venue par jour à quelqu'un
a conclu mme je crois qu'il faudra
compter sur france 3 non puis il
traverse est journaliste et entre par la
grande porte
là où se tient la réunion des ministres
[Musique]
je me suis fait le but de ma question
c'est que les journalistes vous demande
qui vous venez rencontrer que vous dites
je ne sais pas non on apprend que vous
travaillez pour des projets comme ça
comme un projet fou rire de stockage de
déchets nucléaires en avez vous parlé à
quelqu'un gouvernement de ce projet le
non jeu pour parler au premier ministre
ce riche mais je n'ai pas l'intention de
lui en parler du tout non plus je ne
fais pas de la baie pour personne
d'autres personnes qui peuvent vous
aider nos dionne ya peu
y a pas de dossier viavil gorham adha il
ne pas y alliez ils m'aiment pas de
projet je prenais même pas ficelé vous
faites pas de lobbying non vous parlait
jamais des projets des clients à nos à
des personnes qui sont en autorité non
vous l'avez jamais fait non
donc je fais pas de bling pourquoi pas
ce que je pourrais faire de la baie ça
m'intéresse pas d'aller parler aux
fonctionnaires années s'est vu des
fonctionnels à ma vie car en talent chez
moi j'ai mon côté n'est ce pas ce n'est
pas que les japonais se disent
exactement à ceux qui savent ce qu'ils
veulent les japonais je vous dis qu'est
ce que je fais ce serait logique pour
les japonais de penser que jean chrétien
peux ouvrir toutes les bonnes portes
partout au canada compte tenu de ce
qu'il écrit
j'organiserai et participerez à des
discussions au canada dans ces provinces
et dans des pays potentiellement
partenaires pour faire avancer le projet
d'un dépôt en profondeur dans le
nord-est canadien qu'est ce que vous
êtes en japonais vous allez faire jeudi
que
le projet je travaille pour le projet et
j'ai dit que je m'intéresse à ce projet
là je veux que ça marche et dansant la
bayard des discussions et si je peux
participer aux actes ciblés
[Musique]
il a fourni koga a répondu à jean
chrétien
je suis tout à fait disposé à travailler
avec vous j'ai été réellement
impressionné par votre noble idée et par
votre proposition visionnaire une longue
lettre qui se conclut ainsi en terminant
il me fait plaisir d'accepter votre
invitation à une réunion du groupe de
travail à montréal ou à ottawa en
novembre mais il a fourni koga souligner
le caractère secret de leurs discussions
le plus grand soin est nécessaire pour
que cette information ne soit pas
divulguée mais les déchets qui sont
enterrés là ils disparaissent pas fait
ça en mettant une vingtaine d'amis là
bas dit 1000 à 10000 à eybens ya
peut-être un problème un dhimmi leur
laissera aux politiciens de cette époque
là à leur ai dit vous travaillez pas ce
que shaw devient salée et c'est elle
c'est plutôt des associations que des
vérités c'est pas ta le professeur
mais moi je pense que parler d'un projet
secret de site de stockage de déchets
nucléaires mais ce crétin c'est très
bien fait républicain je pense que c'est
doubt intérêts publics
oui j'ai répondu à vos questions ouais
mais il ya peu de signes sa dette quand
vous voyez votre avocat avait tenus au
secret professionnel connaissant pas
combien de dossiers controversés avance
discrètement sous le sceau du secret
professionnel
pour ce qui est du site de stockage de
déchets nucléaires
le débat pourra se poursuivre en public
[Musique]
je